botaram obrigado a todos e obrigado pelo
convite é eu não fui vendo que
convidaram mexe o tempo vamos falar essa
transgressão eu acho que me convidaram
talvez por isto a vossa frente esta
figura e chegou a 53 anos com 29 semanas
e 1 350
portanto eu tive com o deputado doutor
tive que aprender a sobreviver ea
adaptação é uma palavra que cruza a
minha vida para e como elas prolongou ao
longo do tempo não foi só aqui é mais
tarde na escola era conhecido um rótulo
do canina era mais pequeno
depois disso fiquei mal desporto mas
como era em que a partir da adaptação
mas não tinha uma inteligência muito
favorecida escolhi o vasco atual não
correr vai correr até a juve mês
nos juvenis convidaram a ser accionista
e você está com muito gosto por ser o
que era um sinal da adaptação a síria
isso tenta encontrar uma namorada e o
critério foi estreitado por cliff altura
que eu tenho não pretende parar por
muito alto
mais tarde aos 18 anos 17 entre os 17 e
os 18 horas e evitem militar também são
muitas e no concurso aquele mesmo jornal
recorda o nosso alunos às provas vivas
orton infelicidade não cruzar com ele e
quando chegar a altura eu pergunto
quanto e meio do candidato nos 102 você
está no limite certo o coronel
o peso mínimo de 50 que os e eu quem
tinha 50 que os milagres originado os
dois litros de leite no estado
esta é a minha história pessoal de
adaptação eo jogo talvez por isso fiz o
meu percurso na infantaria e e quando
convidaram pt
as castas fui fiz a minha viagem para
psicologia porque enfrentei e tem
equipamentos que não era muito acumulava
em cima de mim com um bom equipamento em
cima e no geral sabe que é verdade eu
queria por lá verá entrou pelo lado
esquerdo mas que iria cair cair o
exército de uma oportunidades e
psicólogo e lançou um desafio
o teu desafio é ajudar os comandantes
das forças álvaro homens e mulheres do
inferno e virem conteúdo é isso meu
trabalho hoje meu trabalho hoje é
colaborar com os comandantes mandar
popular com os dez livros está o
salvaram mais mulheres no inferno e
ajudar em consultas tanto desafios ou
partilhar convosco é um desafio muito
maior do que o que você está indo na
vossa vida em um inferno pode ser isto é
o inferno estranho porque preenchimento
ali tirar sua provável é um cenário até
simpático mas é neste cenário que nós
temos que conviver conicidade
desenvolver perturbação
quem não tiver um equipamento para
aprová lo ou quem não conseguir executar
este cenário e para se adaptar este
cenário acredita que é preciso algum nem
da aprovação porque são normalmente
usadas para fazer desporto mas o
desporto não é incluir e ovar conosco ou
explodir o barco nos cantar nossa volta
as panelas pressão em nossa casa não são
usadas para atingir o objetivo que sejam
três latas saída portanto é paranóia é
um aspecto que aumenta a nossa
capacidade de sobrevivência no campo de
batalha estar vigilantes é um aspecto
que aumenta a nossa capacidade de
sobrevivência no campo de batalha e os
resultados também podem ser este a morte
eo sofrimento
isto não é ficção existe mas estes
homens e mulheres têm família
estes homens e mulheres são homens e
mulheres equilibrados e preparar
o foco em que quando eu quero fechar o
foco eu quero deixar aqui presente o
traem a preparação ea autoconfiança que
o wii
o homem falou dos super heróis estão no
super herói
aliás é este o período que o time vá é
na minha pessoa mágica ter trabalho
autoestima autoconceito e acreditar em
mim próprio e é por isso que eu me sinto
preparado para abraçar com os meus
camaradas dos desafios do kosovo
afeganistão do líbano que moro no iraque
onde quer que estejam muitos portugueses
essa energia é esse trabalho esta
preparação um tem dado capacidade para
nos ajudar e apoiar na essência das
forças armadas que são os seus mandantes
os livros não são os psicólogos não quem
prepara psicologicamente as forças
os livros são os comandantes da
comunidade como eu contei que hoje levam
os homens e as mulheres de transcenderem
se acrescentarem aos próprios
prosseguindo valores fim de objetivos
que ultrapassam e porque o conheço
relativamente bem esta posição do
colégio é que ela é massa é a argamassa
que do sul nessa que é precisar superar
em e suplantar em certas operações desta
são expostas estudo a atividade se nós
não formos a princípio se nós não formos
revestidos com bom senso nem fazer é
aproveitar a oportunidade que o colégio
militar leu para fazer uma pequena
exaltação do soldado português porque o
soldado português com certeza estudo
estudo solar português quando conduzem
cabo e ver uma viatura como a senhora e
uma criança aproximar de deus cumpre as
regras de segurança com as regras de
empenhamento ea convicção companhia com
profissionalismo mas com bom senso não
dispara por que a senhora chegou a três
metros de altura pensa sempre olha esta
feira vai atrasada como páscoa
o melhor e ele já me deixava passar
outras nações não têm essa que precisava
de se aplicarem a circunstância as
regras isso trailers não está na nossa
genética a nossa genética a nossa
capacidade de adaptação como portuguesas
é fabulosa loja e se olharmos para a
história
temos exemplos de adaptação nos mostram
que isso é verdade
o mais recente é é um momento difícil
socialmente difícil economicamente
difícil total viveu e foi através da
adaptação que conseguimos criar
mecanismos de resistência os meus
soldados os meus camaradas aplicam essa
adaptação com flexibilidade utiliza uma
flexibilidade ave adaptação numa mistura
uma combinação promove uma imagem em uma
competência que é assinalável e por
vezes se calhar mais que qualquer
desejável não sendo reconhecida fora das
pretas das forças armadas
estes homens e mulheres vivem este
paradoxo para sobreviverem no campo de
batalha
tem que ter estas capacidades estas
preocupações
estes sinais de perturbação ao cinema
ficando estamos permanentemente
verificar um equipamento
eu não sei como é que tem trocado por
dinheiro e não sei por que um carregador
quatro horas depois de sair do
afeganistão cinco horas depois ter
lucrado estão tão lisboa em lisboa é que
eu vou encontrar em minha família e os
meus amigos e vou fazer a minha vida
normal
o meu desafio o desafio que o exército
lançou é um desafio possível que é o de
ajudar a mudar o chip em seis horas
receptoras no futuro em cinco dias criar
condições para que os homens e as
mulheres que para sobreviver aí tiveram
que se adaptar e criar mecanismos que
quais são perturbadores virarem esposa
virarem hospital
vivem do colombo e quando vamos poder
executivo da loja da nike não olharem
passar por trilhas
assim é que o planeta tem um bingo
assim e não estas seqüências tomar
medidas não estão armazenadas
o telemóvel não estar maravilhado este é
o nosso desafio este é o meu desafio que
o consegue superar este desafio é fato
a combinação da adaptação e
flexibilidade conduz a uma maior
sensação de felicidade
a lição que eu tiro de minha experiência
como psicólogo militar que minha
experiência como militar é promovam em
vós condições de adaptação é exatamente
com flexibilidade e vão com certeza será
mães e mulheres mais felizes por motos
controlado e hoje vimos aqui esse
exemplo o trabalho é o treino não é por
eu falar como psicóloga os meus
camaradas militares que estão preparados
não é dureza do trabalho é emergência no
rio
criam os mecanismos de adaptação é na
exigência do rigor com vós próprios que
disse criar a capacidade e
disponibilidade para conseguir superar
os desafios que temos à nossa frente
por isso a adaptação não é um dom
natural adaptação exige de nós
acorda início de conversa 86 golo do
vasco queria ter suprimido podia ter
encontrado uma maneira de adaptação que
era deixar de fazer desporto mas não
procurei com flexibilidade encontrar
caminhos que lhes fossem alternativos
que me trouxesse alguma felicidade e que
não gostassem do desporto e isso eu sei
que vocês são capazes
portanto resta um desafio trabalhar
trabalhar trabalhar e seguir trabalhar
trabalhar não é suficiente para tirar em
que vivemos hoje é preciso trabalhar
numa matriz valor
enquadrado por uma trilha de valores
respeito com o outro
estamos a falar temos num teste procura
falar liderança
acreditem em nós sozinhos vamos ter
pressa temos mais pressa mas seguramente
juntos conseguimos ir mais longe
por isso não se preocupa em como
incentivar preocupa-se com distância
preocupa se com a forma como leva os
outros conheçam os vossos amigos conheço
os vossos companheiros e juntos vão com
certeza traçar um caminho que é um
caminho que os vai conduzir como a maior
felicidade
esta é a mensagem que os trazia obrigado